hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve meeting rooms two
and just like meeting rooms one we're
going to solve this problem on the
website called
lint code because this is a premium leak
code problem
so if you want to be able to solve it
for free you can use lintcode.com
so it's pretty similar to meeting rooms
one we are given a list of meeting times
each meeting time is an
object and it has two variables it has a
start time
and it has an end time and the end time
is always going to come after the start
time that's pretty intuitive
and we want to know what's the minimum
number of
conference rooms required for all of
these meetings now what they
what they actually mean by conference
rooms is basically
what is the maximum number of
overlapping
meetings at any given point in time so
for example
in this input we have a meeting that
starts at 0 ends at 30. another meeting
that starts at 5 ends at 10
and then another meeting that starts at
15 and ends at 20.
and we would need two meeting rooms for
this problem because we
are gonna have two overlapping meetings
so if we had one room where the zero to
thirty meeting is going on
the five to 10 meeting is basically
going to be going on
during the same time as this one so
we're going to need a second meeting
room for this
and we also have another meeting 15 to
20. now it doesn't overlap with this one
so technically they can be a part of the
same meeting room now we don't actually
need to determine
what goes in each meeting room we just
have to know what's the maximum number
of overlapping meetings at any given
point in time
in this case that happens to be two we
are going to be required to sort the
input array
which is going to take n log n time
complexity so this is going to be the
time complexity
of the algorithm the memory complexity
is going to be big o
of n i'm going to show you how to do the
solution now if you just stare at this
like the problem statement and just look
at these numbers it's going to be
difficult to come up with how to code
the solution but
as you guys know i like to draw pictures
and when you look at the picture it
actually becomes pretty easy
to figure out how to solve this problem
so let's do that so this is kind of how
we can visualize those meetings right
these are the
exact same meetings that we were given
in that first example
we have one meeting going from 0 to 30
another meeting going from 5 to 10 and
another meeting going from 15 to 20. now
if we just go from left to right we're
gonna see
okay well this is the first meeting that
starts right it starts at time zero
and if we just keep going now we see
what's the next point on our grid right
well
there's another meeting and this is not
an end time this is not you know the the
first meeting isn't
ending there just happens to be another
meeting that's starting so another
meeting just started at time
five so what does that tell us that
tells us
two meetings have started so far but
nothing has ended right there's no
meeting that's
ended yet so at this point in time we're
gonna have
two meetings going on at the same amount
of time so what we're gonna be
maintaining is a variable
count which tells us at any given point
in time what is the number of meetings
going on and right now our account is 2
and we're going to end up returning
whatever the max value this happened to
be
so what's the next point on our grid we
visited this one we visited this one
now we're looking at this one right okay
at at time
10 there's an end point this is not a
starting value this is a starting value
this is an
ending value so what does that tell us
that tells us a meeting has just
ended so what are we going to do with
our count we knew we had two meetings
going on at the same time over here
but now after this point we're only
going to have one meeting going on right
like look at the picture
there's only one meeting going on and
it's this first one right zero to 30. so
we're going to set the number of
meetings going on to
one now we're going to look at the next
point in order
now it happens to be a start time so
another meeting just started at time 15
right so once again there are two
meetings going on right at this point
there's two meetings going on the first
one and
this second one so once again a meeting
started that's going to tell us to
increment our
count so now we're gonna say two
meetings are once again going on
and again we're gonna repeat the same
process the next point is at 20 this
happens to be an
end time so that means a meeting is
ending right we don't
we don't technically even know is it
this meeting that's ending or is it this
meeting that's ending it doesn't really
matter to us
all we know is that after this point
only one meeting is gonna be going on at
any particular time and it's gonna be
this one
so we're gonna take our count of
meetings going on decrement it and now
it's gonna be
one and last but not least we're going
to go to the last
point in our grid and it's also a end
time obviously the last point is always
going to be
a end time for a meeting so that means
another meeting is stopping
after that point there's only going to
be you know zero meetings going on
so therefore we can take our count
decrement it all the way down
to zero now we notice that what was the
max value that count happened to be
well the max it ever reached was two so
therefore we're going to return
two as our result two meeting rooms is
enough to contain all of these meetings
so let me show you quickly how we're
actually going to be sorting these
points and how we're going to be able to
iterate through each point in order
regardless of if it's a start time for a
meeting or if it's an
end time for a meeting so i'm going to
slightly change the example in this case
so
just by looking at the picture what do
you think the meeting room's number
would be for this
problem well you see over here there's
gonna be one meeting
going on here there's gonna be two
meetings here there's gonna be two
meetings here there's gonna be one
meeting but look at this point at
point time equals 10 clearly there's
three
meetings going on at this time or at
least three meetings have a 10 value
included in their time
interval does that mean that there's
going to be three meetings going on
well technically the way this problem is
defined this meeting would
end before this meeting started what i'm
saying is these two meetings are
non-overlapping so when we are going
through this point if we ever have a
tie meaning if we ever have two points
with the exact same value
what we're gonna do is we're always
gonna iterate through the
end meeting time before we iterate
through the start
meeting time right notice how this is a
end time this is a start time we're
always gonna pick
this one if we ever get a tie like this
so we're actually going to have
two input arrays we're not just going to
sort every meeting based on the start
time what i'm going to do is i'm going
to put all start times in a separate
array
so 0 5 and 10 are all gonna go in a
separate
array these are all the start times for
any meeting right this way
we have them in sorted order and we know
okay these are the ones
that are start times we can
differentiate between a start time and
an
end time we're also going to put every
end time
in an array as well in sorted order so
we can see the first is 10
next 15 next 30. so now we're going to
start this problem off with two pointers
we're going to have one pointer at the
beginning of start and one pointer at
the beginning of end
we're always between these two we're
always going to pick the minimum value
so
we are going to maintain a count which
tells us the number of meetings that are
going
on and if the minimum between these two
is the start time what we're going to do
is we're going to increment the count of
meetings going on and then shift our
start pointer to the next one
and we can see that that's the case
again right 5 is less than 10 therefore
a meeting has to start before this
meeting ends
so once again we're going to shift our
pointer over here and we're going to
increment our count by one so
the count is now gonna be set to two and
now we get to the edge case right we got
a tie so
a meeting is ending and a meeting is
starting remember we are gonna
visit the end time if there's a tie
first so what we're gonna say
now is that okay a meeting has to end
before this meeting starts so we're
gonna shift our
end pointer to the next one if we
iterate through an end value that means
a meeting just ended therefore we're
gonna decrement our count by one so
two is decremented by one it's going to
be set to one now
now again we're going to compare these
two values 10 and 15. which one is
smaller the 10 right so therefore
another meeting is starting
so we're going to increment our count by
one so count is now going to be equal to
two and now we don't even have any start
times
left so technically at this point we're
just going to be iterating through the
end time so we're literally just going
to be decrementing this so we iterate
through this
decrement this down to one iterate
through this decrement this down to zero
so technically
once we've gotten through all start
times we don't even have to iterate
through
the remaining portion of end times so
what we can say is that our max count
at any given point it reached was two so
therefore we're going to return
two so that is basically the algorithm
we're going to use
and coding it up isn't going to be too
difficult yes we are going to have to
create two separate arrays start and end
and we're going to sort these input
arrays so the time complexity is going
to be n log n the memory complexity is
going to be big o of
n that being said let's jump into the
code now on lint code
so like i said we are going to create a
array for all start times in sorted
order now i'm sure you know how to do
that in your language of choice
but in python there's a pretty easy way
to do it so we're going to go through
for every interval
in the list of intervals that we're
given now
an interval is an object as defined up
above it as two member variables start
and end so since this arrays start we're
going to put every start time of this
interval
in this input array and don't forget we
are going to sort it so and i can do
that
on the same line just like this we're
going to have a similar array for n
times basically doing the exact same
thing so a sorted input array
of i dot n for every interval in the
list of
intervals now we are going to have a
result variable and a count variable so
count is just going to be whatever what
i basically said it was going to be
result is just going to continuously be
whatever the max we have reached so far
for the count variable
and we are also going to have two
pointers i'm just going to name them s
and e uh they're initially going to be
both
zero so s is gonna be the position we're
at in our start array e
is gonna be the position we're at in our
end array and i'm basically just going
to keep
going while s has not reached the
end of intervals because we know of
course s
is going to reach the end before e does
because the start times are always
before the end times
so remember we have two cases if the
start if the position that we're at in
our start array
is less than the position we're at in
our end array
and the other case would be if the end
array
was greater than the s than the start
array which would be the else case but
also if these were
equal we're also going to do the else
case because if they're equal then we
want to make sure we increment our e
pointer first
so that's exactly what we would do here
we would take e
increment increment it by one and
to our count decrement it by one the
opposite is going to be true up here so
here
since s is smaller since the start time
is smaller we're going to be
shifting our s pointer and we're going
to be incrementing the count so we do
have one additional meeting going
on right now that's what we're saying
and after every
iteration basically we're gonna update
our result potentially we always want it
to be the maximum that we've reached so
far for count so we're gonna just take
the max
of result and count once that is done
that means
this loop once this loop is done that
means we've finished all of our start
times
so at that point we can basically return
our result because we've ensured that it
has reached whatever the maximum it was
going to be
and with all that we can go ahead and
submit it hopefully this works
and as you can see it does it's about as
efficient as it would get
so this is the entire code it's not too
bad once you can kind of visualize what
is actually going on that's how you can
kind of figure out
how to put the different points inside
of separate input arrays
but i think it would be pretty difficult
to come up with this on your own in like
a very short interview
but i hope this was helpful if it was
please like and subscribe it supports
our channel
a lot and i'll hopefully see you pretty
soon thanks for watching